فيها جويت بيجريبيراندس ستيشن
[موسيقى]
والتضليل هي ساحه مشتعله بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين
اعلان مسؤولين
ادت لتاخير حساب قرابه 400,000 صوت اضافه
الى التخلف عن فرز اكثر من نصف مليون
بطاقه اقتراعا عبر البريد دفع المرشحه
الجمهوريه كاريك لاطلاق وابل من الاتهامات
بالتقسيط والتشكيك بنزاهه عمليه الاقتراع
الوان
تعد من الولايات الامريكيه المحوريه التي
سيكون لها تاثير بالغ في الانتخابات
النصفيه لكنها ايضا اشتهرت عام 2020 بعد
اللقط الواسع الذي شاب نتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه حينها واعلن الحزب الجمهوري عدم
ثقته بنظام الاقتراع فيها حيث تحدث الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب عن حصول عمليات تزوير
وسعه النطاق في اريزونا ادت لفوز الرئيس
الحالي
من قبل المحاكم الفيدراليه ووزاره العدل
لكنها اتهامات كانت ولازالت المرشحه
الجمهوريه
لها وفي محاولتها للفوز بمنصب الحاكم عادت
لترفع ذات الشعر
يا باكر
رساله مختلفه لمؤيدها على النقيض تماما
اشادت بمن يديرون الاقتراع في مقاطعه
اريزونا واعرضت عن ثقتها لما ال اليه
التصويت ونتائجه
الاصوات